KIMBERLY GUILFOYLE,
JUAN WILLIAMS, JESSE WATTERS,
AND GREG GUTFELD, WHOSE PHONE IS
IMPOSSIBLE TO TURN OFF.
IT'S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE" ."
THE SIGNIFICANT DEVELOPMENT,
MAJOR BREAKTHROUGH IF TRUE.
KIM JONG UN IS SIGNALING HE IS
WILLING TO DENUCLEARIZE NORTH.
IF THE U.S. AGREES TO TALK.
THE SURPRISING NEWS CAME OUT OF
A MEETING BETWEEN THE DICTATOR
AND A SOUTH KOREAN DELEGATION.
PRESIDENT TRUMP REACTED WITH
CAUTIOUS OPTIMISM.
>> WE HAVE COME CERTAINLY A LONG
WAY AT LEAST RHETORICALLY.
WITH NORTH KOREA.
IT WOULD BE A GREAT THING FOR
THE WORLD, A GREAT THING FOR
NORTH KOREA, A GREAT THING FOR
THE PENINSULA.
WE WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
WE HAVE MADE PROGRESS, NO
QUESTION.
>> Dana: THE PRESIDENT
CREDITING SANCTIONS AS A
MOTIVATION FOR NORTH KOREA TO
COME TO THE TABLE.
>> I THINK THEY ARE SINCERE BUT
I THINK THEY ARE SINCERE ALSO
BECAUSE THE SANCTIONS AND WHAT
WE ARE DOING WITH RESPECT TO
NORTH KOREA, INCLUDING THE GREAT
HELP WE'VE BEEN GIVEN FROM
CHINA, THEY CAN DO MORE.
I REALLY BELIEVE THEY ARE
SINCERE.
I HOPE THEY ARE SINCERE.
>> Dana: THE PRESIDENT TAKING
A CAUTIOUS APPROACH, SKEPTICAL
BUT OPTIMISTIC.
NOT EVERYBODY FEELS THE SAME
WAY.
JOHN BOLTON, FORMER U.S.
>> THE ONLY THING NORTH KOREA IS
SERIOUS ABOUT IS DELIVERABLE
NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
BY ALL ACCOUNTS, THEY ARE VERY
CLOSE TO ACHIEVING AN OBJECTIVE
THEY'VE BEEN AFTER FOR 25 YEARS.
WHY DO THEY WANT TO TALK NOW?
I WILL BET YOU A DOLLAR AS WE
ARE SITTING HERE TODAY YOU ARE
GOING TO HEAR ALMOST IMMEDIATELY
THE UNITED STATES HAS TO
CONTRIBUTE TO THE ATMOSPHERE.
WE'VE GOT TO SHOW GOOD FAITH.
PRIME THE PUMP, ALL OF WHICH IS
CODE TALK.
I THINK YOU CAN COUNT ON THIS.
NORTH KOREA WILL GET DELIVERABLE
NUCLEAR WEAPONS BEFORE THE END
OF THE YEAR.
>> Dana: JOHN BOLTON WITH
FRANK TALK ON NORTH KOREA.
>> Greg: IT'S GOOD TO BE
SKEPTICAL.
EVEN IF WHAT NORTH KOREA SAID IS
BALONEY, IT'S NEW BALONEY.
SKEPTICISM SHOULD ALWAYS BE
WHERE YOU ARE FROM.
WHAT WOULD YOU RATHER HEAR THAN
THIS?
IF YOU ARE HEARING SOMETHING
POSITIVE, SURE, YOU WOULD LIKE
THEM TO SAY WE ARE GOING TO END
LABOR CAMPS AND GO TO A FREE
MARKET SYSTEM.
IN THE SPECTRUM OF POSITIVE
AND IT IS NEW.
THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT GETTING
TOGETHER FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
TEN YEARS.
I DON'T THINK THEY HAVE TALKED
ABOUT DENUCLEARIZATION AS PART
OF THE PLAN.
IF THIS HAPPENED UNDER OBAMA,
THE NOBEL PEACE PRIZE WOULD'VE
BEEN SHIPPED AMAZON PRIME NEXT
DAY DELIVERY.
I THOUGHT TRUMP'S RESPONSE WAS
PRETTY RESERVED.
IT COULD HAPPEN, COULD NOT
HAPPEN.
I WILL TAKE THEM AT THEIR WORD
AND SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
WE ALL KNOW BOLTON IS VERY
CONSISTENT ON THIS.
MUSTACHE.
>> Dana: THE PRESIDENT RIGHTLY
SAYING THAT ONE OF THE WAYS, ONE
OF THE REASONS YOU HAVE THIS NEW
DEVELOPMENT ABOUT HOW IT TURNS
OUT IS BECAUSE THE SANCTIONS ARE
STARTING TO HAVE AN EFFECT.
>> ROCKET MAN IS CRAZY.
HE THIS COULD BE A PLOY.
AT THE SAME TIME, IT'S A
POSITIVE DEVELOPMENT, AS GREG
SAID.
WHERE ARE THE DEMOCRATS?
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN SAYING
THAT THIS TOUGH TALK WOULD LEAD
TO WAR.
ALL WE NEED TO DO IS SIT DOWN AT
THE TABLE.
POINT OF POTENTIAL DIPLOMACY AND
TALKS.
NO I DON'T HEAR ANYTHING FROM
THE DEMOCRATS.
THE DEMOCRATS WILL NEVER GIVE
ANYBODY CREDIT, ESPECIALLY
DONALD TRUMP, WHEN SOMETHING
HAPPENS POSITIVE, FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
I THINK BOTH PARTIES ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THIS.
PELOSI, THEY CALLED IT CRUMBS.
HAIRY REED WOULDN'T ADMIT IT
WORKED.
THERE WERE REPUBLICANS WHO
WOULDN'T GIVE OBAMA CREDIT FOR
KILLING BIN LADEN.
I GET IT.
THE MEDIA SAID THIS WOULD LEAD
TO WAR.
ALL THESE WAR GAMES.
THE MEDIA SHOULD BE DISCREDITED
BECAUSE IT LED TO THE OPPOSITE.
IT'S BECAUSE I DON'T REPORT
CAUSE AND EFFECT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYS SOME THINGS
IN BORDER CROSSINGS ARE DOWN AND
NATO COUNTRIES ARE PONYING UP
MONEY.
ISIS IS DECIMATED.
THESE ARE THE RESULTS OF TRUMP
RHETORIC, ACTION, AND POLICY.
THE MEDIA WON'T TELL YOU THE
WHOLE STORY.
THEY ARE ONLY REPORTING THINGS
IN ISOLATION BECAUSE THEY ARE
DISHONEST.
>> Dana: I HAVEN'T HEARD THE
DEMOCRATS SAY ANYTHING.
>> Greg: GIVE THEM TIME.
>> Dana: MEANING THEY HAVEN'T
SAID ANYTHING POSITIVE OR
NEGATIVE.
ALTHOUGH IT'S JUST HAPPENED
TODAY.
>> Juan: HERE IS WHAT I HAVE
TO SAY.
IF IT SNOWS IN BOSTON OR
NEW YORK CITY IN THE NEXT TWO
DAYS, DONALD TRUMP IS RIGHT
ABOUT GLOBAL WARMING.
THAT WILL BE THE PROOF.
WHEN HE IS TALKING ABOUT MY
BUTTON IS BIGGER THAN YOUR
BUTTON THEN YOU WILL -- WHEN YOU
ARE TALKING THAT WAY TO SOMEONE,
WE AGREE IS A BIT OF A NUTCASE,
KIM JONG UN.
AMERICANS HAVE A RIGHT TO WORRY
WHY IS THE PRESIDENT ENGAGING AT
THAT LEVEL WITH SOMEONE WHO IS
IMPETUOUS.
IT HAS BROUGHT US NOWHERE.
>> Jesse: HISTORIC
NEGOTIATIONS.
NO.
CAN I FINISH?
>> Juan: HAS NOTHING TO DO
WITH DONALD TRUMP'S RHETORIC.
THERE'S A BETTER CASE TO BE MADE
IF IT HAS SOMETHING TO DO WITH
SANCTIONS.
THE EFFECT WE'VE HAD IN TRYING
TO GET CHINA AND OTHERS,
INCLUDING RUSSIA, RELUCTANTLY TO
SOMEHOW GIVE THEM CREDIT.
THIS IS A RESULT, THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS SAID AS MUCH.
THEY DIDN'T LIKE THE IDEA OF THE
TWO CURIOS MERGING TOGETHER AT
THE OLYMPICS.
THEY DIDN'T LIKE THE IDEA OF
PRESIDENT MOON OF SOUTH KOREA
ENGAGING IN TALKS INDEPENDENTLY
POTENTIALLY UNDERCUTTING U.S.
EFFORTS.
AND NOW YOU GET A RESULT OF THE
SOUTH KOREAN.
I AM SAYING TO SIT HERE AND SAY.
>> Dana: LET ME GET KIMBERLY
IN.
NOT WITHOUT POSSIBLE CONCERNS.
THERE ARE -- WE DON'T HAVE AN
INVESTOR IN SOUTH KOREA.
>> Juan: ASSISTANT SECRETARY
FOR ASIAN AFFAIRS.
>> Dana: THAT'S TRUE.
>> Greg: OH, MY GOD, WHAT WILL
WE DO?
>> Dana: YOU HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR DIPLOMACY.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION WOULD
WANT REINFORCEMENTS ESPECIALLY
IF ONE OF THE GOALS OF
NORTH KOREA IS TO SPLIT OFF
SOUTH KOREA FROM ITS STRONG
ALLIANCE WITH THE UNITED STATES.
THAT'S WHAT I WAS TRYING TO SAY.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Kimberly: WELL STATED.
>> Dana: THANK YOU, KIMBERLY.
>> Kimberly: DEMOCRATS,
REPUBLICANS, EIGHT INDEPENDENTS,
UNDECIDEDS, WHATEVER YOU ARE,
UNREGISTERED.
YOU WOULD BE HAPPY ABOUT THIS.
WHY WOULDN'T YOU WANT TO HAVE AN
ATTEMPT AT LEAST AT THOUGHTFUL
CONSISTENT NEGOTIATIONS TO TRY
TO WORK ON ELIMINATING, REDUCING
THE THREAT OF NUCLEAR WAR.
IF THEY'RE WILLING TO COME TO
THE TABLE AND THEY ARE SINCERE
AND EARNEST AND WE WILL GIVE IT
A VERY DISCERNING EYE, AS
AMBASSADOR BOLTON SAID.
IF THE PRESIDENT DIDN'T PUT OUT
A TWEET LIKE THIS, YOU WOULD SEE
THE LIBERALS SCREAMING CRAZY
TOWN.
GIVE PEACE A CHANCE.
FINGER HAPPY, YOU WANT TO PUT
YOUR FINGER ON THE BUTTON.
IF HE SAID LITTLE ROCKET MAN
SAYS HE WANTS TO NEGOTIATE,
DOUBT IT.
>> Dana: I LIKE HOW THEY DO
THIS ON NORTH KOREA, THE GOOD
COP-BAD COP THING.
REX TILLERSON SAID NORTH KOREA
THREATENS THE ENTIRE GLOBAL
COMMUNITY.
MUST BE A GLOBAL EFFORT.
HE IS TRYING.
>> Greg: PART OF THE WHOLE
IDEA OF WHAT WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT WITH ISIS AND STUFF.
UNPREDICTABILITY.
IT'S KIND OF NICE WHEN AMERICA
IS THE "CRAZY PERSON" ON THE
BLOCK.
WE HAVE BEEN THE PERSON THAT THE
CRAZY PERSON SAYS DEATH TO
AMERICA.
NOW WE ARE THE UNPREDICTABLE
PERSON AND THE UNPREDICTABILITY
RESETS THE TABLE WITH
NORTH KOREA.
IT'S RESET THE TABLE AND OTHER
AREAS AS WELL.
YOU LOOK AT CERTAIN THINGS.
EVEN WITH THE IMMIGRATION.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT IS COMING.
THINGS CHANGE BECAUSE OF THAT.
I DISAGREE.
I DON'T THINK KIM JONG UN IS
CRAZY.
I THINK HE'S A RATIONAL ACTOR.
THIS IS WHAT HE'S DOING TO MAKE
SURE HE SURVIVES.
I THINK HE IS FIGURING OUT THIS
IS GOING INTO A DIFFERENT PHASE.
WHEN HE SAYS SOMETHING LIKELY
WILL DO NUCLEARIZE IF WE FEEL
YOU AREN'T -- THAT'S A
RATIONAL STATEMENT.
LIKE BOLTON SAYS, HE COULD BE
LYING.
THE THING IS, TO JESSE'S POINT,
WHICH IS TRUE, AND KIMBERLY.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO LIKE
DONALD TRUMP TO ADMIT NOW AND
THEN THAT PROGRESS IS MADE.
NONE OF YOUR FRIENDS ARE GOING
TO THINK LESS OF YOU BECAUSE YOU
CAN'T ADMIT THAT HE ACTUALLY DID
SOMETHING PRETTY GOOD.
THE PROBLEM IS, HE'S DONE FIVE
PRETTY GOOD THINGS THIS YEAR.
>> Juan: LIKE WHAT?
>> Greg: DO YOU WANT TO START
WITH ISIS?
THE TAX CUTS, NORTH KOREA?